guarda io non ho fatto neanche le
elementari non lo metta nessuno però
sapere questo
wow grazie a tutti ragazzi benvenute
questo video sono parigi oggi sono con
il buon sasha che mi accompagna e piange
e fa cose vedevo l'ora di rivederti
fratello minore visto nel frattempo per
arrotondare giusto che si guadagna poco
iniziato a fare il frutti 20 dai
lancieri la frutta che la vediamo al
bancone oggi ragazzi con sasha mentre
minaccia i pomodori che io schivo al
volo e facciamola bolkan oran che
sarebbe tipo una roba di tipo temporaneo
per opere pomodori capito allora
teoricamente questo dovrebbe essere un
tempo run molto più vulcanico quindi non
non mi chiedo mi chiedere perché non lo
so non l'ho mai fatto
dobbiamo sopravvivere arrivare al finale
tutto qua ma è pronto non idonei come si
faccia non mi chiedo è veramente non lo
so sono tipo valore
devi correre
ma non ci rincorre niente sono morto
forse non siamo partiti benissimo io non
capisco se c'è un muro che ci segue
perché però non ci segue niente per ora
per ora però porca vacca sono scarso
ricaduto l'iva su presta parte maledetta
bene che sembra una cavolata ma abbiamo
scoperto che c'è il muro che ci segue
bene cosi come un puledro altre corriamo
insieme a casa ok allora indiana fare
iva il signor è una famiglia ha
funzionato se bravissimo ha funzionato
sasha sei fortissimo a dare i consigli
se bravissimo arriva prossimo c'e poi
tutto lo prendo sto scherzando sono
morto però andata bene ho creduto
tantissimo
ok più andato vai vai fascia perché se
poi arriva arriva è difficilissimo
perché il muro è difficilissima c'è un
certo è insicuro e lorenzo sono veloci
sono veloce ci sto provando te lo giuro
perché davis ha dato un casinò a non
dire che sia morto a orto
ok di queste ho fatto di questo fatto ha
fatto altro ceppo iphone sotto c'è point
fetta dio e castellino massima 20 minuti
finiamo se sì sì sì sì sì sì nostro
sicuro non è partito il mio ma è il mio
ma il muro non c'è ai miei musicisti c'è
dietro di te esattamente dietro idea
c'è poi l'ho preso l'ho preso forse l'ho
preso forse l'ho preso più sorpreso a
noi una moneta porca vacca non c'è ma
non ci sei c'è poi ma quando ti giuro
sono andato avanti sino adesso dojo più
avanti di così non solo aria lo ha fatto
sei salti è veramente un casino perché
poi la scelta di chi viene a correre
bassa
a me piace ridurlo non i tronchi vai di
twixt boia del quale va a destra
ok ho iniziato a prenderci è un po la
mano ho iniziato a prender cibo a posto
e un po io non riesco solo a chi ha
schierato giusto ok non record nuovo
record su record
io sono records che ritmo record scritto
io vedo però ce lo metto io dico porca
vacca bravo avanti bravissimo insieme
qual cosa stai facendo gravissimo bravo
chi ho rischiato lì ok vaio e cori come
un puledro lascia con puledro ai
panthers card bye bye bye baby
no ero dietro il giorno sono mortoni 1
st 3 2 1
vedi se arriviamo prima del pomodoro
alla fine si può fare da pomodori run to
milan ci pomodori io scappo grillo
aspetta la vittoria reale subito capito
mamma mia quanto miu miu store a parte
la scrivania io chiamo il falegname le
faccio fare un'altra presentano ti prego
prima trovare un'altra se non è lui che
fa le mappe di forni e del falegname
perché sa che gli dai lavoro capit nome
dell'oracolo lì che dobbiamo usare così
forti è la palpebra g ai media il medico
è lì che diciamo un primo fermo con la
frattura ad un braccio medici
specializzati in fratture di forte a
morire morirò adesso anche veggente sono
a nostra volta lascia mai mai mai mai
più
cosa è vera vincitrici del partito hai
superato il punto perché io ti ok qua fa
muoio io sono l'altra faccia poi ho
visto io ho visto no visto ho visto il
muro mi son cagato addosso
ok ok ok ok ok ci piace ci piace l'ho
visto selvaggio che casino ho preso la
netta tra l'altro dai recenti accordi ma
non c'è un soft toys scusami beh guarda
che che poi tutto sommato non siano
neanche male e solo che è veramente
difficile
ok che giusto quaggiù giusto bravissima
mamamia sta arrivando di nuovo
ok ok ghiaccio qua gli ace quaglia c'è
qua parlando fortissimo ce l'ho fatto ci
ha fatto assodato dopo a dopo il
ghiaccio dopo classi sono dopo i ghiacci
kribi la prima reparto motto sono dopato
tantissimo oddio io cos'è la zona
nuovissima lo passa in mezzo alle porte
alle porte c'è una scala saltando su
alta scala
oddio centro momento che l'ho preso
quando non basta basta basta però basta
proprio come basta pronuncia farò mai
più
dobbiamo stare lì fine ha fatto il 70
per cento
praticamente non ce la farò mai più ad
arrivare mai più fidati problemi che
continua a prendersi mai maiali di
muretti porco demonio porco sempre lì mi
sono fermato troppe volte cose non
memoria è figura del suo che muoio st
partecipa fatta che è strano è invece
non molto malumore non ci credo ma dopo
ghiaccio se di nuovo a nostro carico
proprio lui ma non c'è più il muro qua o
ce n'è un altro che parte forze a tu
dici a una certa fini delle scelte non
c'è più attenzione a ma lei io questo
arrivato io loro prima tournée stati ti
aspetto del porca vacca il salto della
fede ok ok buono se arrivato vivo la
parte nuova perfetto l'effetto effetto
che è soprattutto ghiaccio si sta perché
non mi riesce male e quello dopo che il
casino che non ho ancora capito
benissimo benissimo record record nuova
zona
nella zona non sono solo sono solo sono
solo sono solo sono solo sono seduti e
concentrati no ma basta basta basta
veramente basta fino qua 80 per cento
filati roll all 85 l'ho vista più o meno
2 fisciano sa portare basta non arriverò
mai basta mai fatto ma non riesco e non
riesco difficile se non prendi il bari
ma pari a boccheggiare ok ok madonna che
salto pagasse la mia vita fa schifo se
non riesco a fare un temporale come
posso pretendere di vivere una mia breve
però lo capisco perché questo è un
temporaneo abbastanza difficile record
nuovo è una macchina e poi cosa cha cha
cha e risulta dai primi no
no no io no ti prego vai xkè c'è un
punto c'è un punto dove ti toglie la
supervelocità te la toglie e se sì sì a
le puy saltari direttore in plastica al
ponte dopo se io lo faccio col demonio
parto vai vai vai vai vai così bravo
bravo siamo arrivati al ghiaccio sachs a
buy
sbatti sul legno legno il proprio spazio
legno bravo vai litrico subito a destra
sui temi sepolte tranquillo arrivi
quadri qua no non meno lo è ma sai che
non mi è mai arrivato la prima volta
donna mi sento ninja mondo per questa
parte non guardano anche dove vado ok
dopo il muro già però vabbè potranno
mettere il muro che andava ma proprio
quel mezzo ben altro di meno ok record
all time giorno un botto 3
lascia sfilare
si no wow
cos'è cos'è
cosa è successo quando mancava non sai
bene che si no
maledizione alla vita alla vita
l'ultimo tentativo dopo anni è o non è
mezza che richiama stava al 90 per cento
alle fatto io sono arrivato a 60 fu la
viene a di guarda lascia stare perché
dopo inguardabili fate l'ultimo deve
essere buono però considerato andiamo
sotto io ho sentito questa di molti talk
assalti nuovo caiatino salto e invece no
ora come la paga bene guarda lo guarda
come esperto ormai richiami a memoria le
mattonelle sappiamo a meno di ormai sono
ormai andiamo veramente tutto l'amore è
un angolo maledetto quello ragazzi a
vedrai prova arrivare vediamo di arrivo
però veramente un inferno un inferno
teatro secci ecco se ci fossero i
circuiti sarebbe fattibilissima sono
solo se per i check point che però vabbè
tempo organicista che non ci siano dice
quanti contemporaneo
no non ci sta anche che ogni anno
penso che fai la scuola è arrivato un
muro in faccia sasha aiuto spero che vi
sia piaciuto ringrazio sasha per aver
partecipato lascio su canali descrizione
hanno assicurato non si non si muore se
proficua e video vi è piaciuto e se non
si piace e noi ci vediamo come sempre la
parola visto che ad agganciare i
pomodori dai ragazzi
[Musica]